is with us in Florida hey Kirk how are
you excellent how about you better than
I deserve what's up I'm small business
owner
thank you a large part to you I've been
debt free for north of 10 years now
good and part of the problem with being
debt-free is I also have the credit
report to show for it meaning I have no
credit one hasn't had a credit card it's
yeah thank you me neither so anyhow
small business owner and my bank it's a
small regional bank and they ran out of
the paycheck protection program money
like in about five minutes
and they ran out before I had a chance
to apply so I use your revenues down yes
how much yo right now I'm probably down
for the for the three months about forty
percent for the two months about doing
what looking a business what's a
business I have a Jewelry and Loan okay
okay a pawn shop that specializes in
jewelry don't you okay okay so I thought
all other alternatives to get the
paycheck protection because everybody
stayed on payroll even the far even
though there are you know our revenues
and everything down we'd continue to pay
our staff are you actually losing money
yet or are your revenues just down I
mean loss of profit negative profit yeah
probably not quite negative but not far
from it so you're you're around breaking
even okay have you all when you're in
Florida so you start reopening right
yeah they never close pawn shops in
Florida they Demuth's of financial
services oh okay so your central ok ok
yeah but so that's why your revenues off
but it's not gone okay that makes sense
but as Florida has begun to reopen how
as your customer base started to come
back slowly yeah okay right now there so
you're you think you're on the upswing
not the bottom
probably in the middle you'll come at
least from a retail standpoint lots of
the loan redemptions because the
government's playing around so much free
money yeah yeah so yep Mike my loan
balance is way way down yeah your margin
but that helps your cash position yeah
I'd like to know a little bit about your
war chest what do you I mean what do you
have in terms of retained earnings in
the business or personally and your
ability to not pay yourself for a while
I mean can I make a few more weeks
easily okay so don't take the longer
yeah okay you don't need the loan no no
I I don't need it right okay but I mean
from what I understand if you're
continuing to pay your employees whether
you need it or not it's still forgivable
if they don't screw around with it it's
a twenty three hundred page document and
last time I checked they promised to
forgive student loans in certain
scenarios - but they haven't and if you
haven't dealt with the SBA they're the
DMV of the federal government there are
screwed up delayed incompetent bunch of
characters and the last thing I want is
alone I've been advising people not to
take these loans under any circumstances
in your situation it doesn't even hurt
you to not take it you're gonna be just
fine you've you know you've got smacked
in the face but it's not gonna cause you
to close if you miss out on this loan I
wouldn't do it I wouldn't step in the
bear trap man yeah the way you said it
Kirk you said I don't need it and the
rest of that sentence well as you wanted
what's the free money a bit forgiving
but he doesn't need it and that's what
we got to make her decisions it's not
free money I mean exactly down down the
road you know my tax is gonna go off my
everything's going to go off you know
even if I don't need it now you're in
the future and as revenues continue
thanks your taxes are gonna go down
because you've got some ride offs under
the Care Act that you ain't even found
yet cuz you ain't gone to your tax
preparer I spent two and a half hours
looking at the increase write-off so
we've got this morning it's incredible
how much my tax bill went
this year because of the Care Act
there's stuff in there I didn't even
know was in there I've been with my tax
guy all morning which is a dadgum joy
but but it was a joy because I was
actually making money on this
conversation one of the few times I met
with him that was fun well here's the
thing Kirk's competitive and I'm
competitive and I and I respect you know
you start the year with a goal and you
want to do anything you can to continue
to hit that and it's okay if this isn't
your best year ever you know it's it's
okay that you had a little disruption
and you're getting back on your feet but
don't do something stupid just to hit
the goal no matter what because you want
to compete make sure that you do it's
gonna be a rough year and then next year
is gonna be better and you're gonna be
back on the trajectory that you were
pretty soon when everything bounces back
hurt you got out of that and you don't
have a credit score because you didn't
like loans and now you're struggling and
twisting in the wind trying to figure
out a way to get a loan I understand it
has forgiveness provisions but I got to
tell you it's gonna be problems and
there's already been articles in the
Wall Street Journal about the problems
has already been articles in Forbes on
about the problems they're starting to
pop up I was the only one out there
saying for people not to take these
loans and now it's starting to be cool
to tell people to not take these loans
but anytime it has the word loan in the
sentence you called Dave Ramsey you're
gonna get the same answer even if it has
forgiveness provisions student loans
have forgiveness provisions but the word
loan is in the sentence and I'm just not
gonna go there life is too short for me
to be screwing around with a barrel of
snakes and then wonder how to not get
bit and that's that's the problem you
can do what you want to Kirk but our
advice is don't take the PvP loans to
anyone in your case you don't even need
it you're just looking at it as quote
unquote free money and can you dispute
the phrase or whatever that doesn't
matter but it's you know you don't have
to pay it back well you can call it
whatever you wanna call it if you meet
the guidelines if they don't change the
guidelines if they don't screw around
with this whole thing and there's a too
many ifs and the word loan is in the
sentence I'm never going back there's
not enough money on the planet to get me
to step up into that noose and go please
don't drop the trapdoor please don't
drop the trapdoor I'm not doing that